that's the hustle culture too you gotta
wake up and be like okay gotta grind out
my bullying today
let me try to acquire the basketball
cards I knew he needed and I would just
Bogart that much to be like I'm not
trading this one out now I'm sorry
[Music]
welcome back to another spectacular
episode be careful boys today we have
Colleen Joe Bart Nick Steve Green hey
[Applause]
okay what's the time that you guys uh
bullied somebody and you felt it was
justified I never blew anybody not blue
I didn't I didn't blow anybody I swear
I never feel alive
well if it's Justified is it bullying or
is it just like well it's bullying until
someone realizes it's Justified so if is
there a time that you bullied somebody
and it appeared like it was bullied I
did a lot of accidental bullying how
does that work so
there was intentional bullying so okay
I'll tell you in elementary school
I was like this is like a very jail
mentality but it was like I'm gonna get
the biggest guy and I'm gonna [__]
harass him bully him oh and then and if
if I keep bullying big people like the
biggest people that No One's Gonna bully
me and it worked right but then I felt
bad because I was like oh they're even
though they're big like doesn't mean
that they're aggressive they're like
kind hardest yeah they're like big bears
they're nice and I just like oh I was
just bullying people for no reason
because I was afraid to get bullied oh
but I wasn't getting bullied so I used
them
you're taking preventative measures yeah
thinking that someone's gonna bully me
but I was only getting bullied at church
never at school what did you do to bully
like what was the action we would just
pick up you just run up to him and just
start [__] with them like throw stuff at
that you know like yeah you just pick
fights with them I even had this I even
have my other friend go behind their
back so I could run up and push them and
then when they fall there's my friend
yeah and then he falls backwards so just
like things like that
and then uh so that was like fourth
grade fifth grade and then like later on
like I I don't uh like I don't Target
people like that right but the bullying
later I thought we were having fun
together but it was just me having fun
and laughing so hard
that I was like that's bullying that's
not just joking like I didn't know that
I was like picking on people because
it's at their expense yeah like
sometimes it's just fun to like do stuff
and then you just crying and laughing
because it's so funny and like you're
just hazing and you're just like like
like swing like we would grab the
younger kids and eighth grade and and
then hold them you like hammock swing
them yeah
they're almost hard as we could in this
in the sand
it's like throwing them into therapy
we're just seeing their body like fly
that way and it's just anyway people cry
too like I didn't think that it was like
pain cry yeah I just yeah but I know
they were crying along without
performative yeah because it hurt not
yeah but then we made them come back so
then we do it again and we throw them in
the sandbag yeah hey get over here
that's pretty accidental I think when
you make them come back yeah
four or five times
but that's a good example I didn't
really register that they really didn't
want that and they weren't my friends oh
until later until I was like oh we were
that's bullying like you think
everyone's friends and you're [__]
around because like I got bullied too
but I didn't know that was bullying so
like my brother would uh make up like
let's say like a rubber band gun or
something yeah and then like he needs a
Target so he would make me run back and
forth like a duck in the in the in the
in the backyard so he could just hit me
with it yeah like a duck so you're on
your hands I have to go quack quack
quack quack quack
you think you're in on a game no I hated
it oh you hate it I [__] hate it it
hurt but you're dedicated though well if
you didn't if you refused to do it what
would be the um I'm scared but but then
I don't know like when you're a kid I
don't think you have empathy and you
don't connect that that's yeah but then
when you're on the giving end it's so
funny and you're just dying and you
can't control it and you said in here
bro like a decade older than you yeah
he's like 12 years older
that reminds me of recreating like we
were watching WWF and [__] and we were
recreating wrestling moves in the
basement but then I was the biggest one
so I was the one like I was the
one doing the moves yeah the Big Show
and they were the dummy basically yeah
so then like but don't you feel alive
though 100 it's so funny I jacked knife
my friend Stanley Wong through his
[__] closet door and snatched it in
half you lifted him up and then yeah
dude I [__] jackknifed him right
through the all the way through the
closet door and I watched it snap in
half and I was like oh [__] and then I
heard his mom I heard his mom like
[__] yelling in Cantonese upstairs
and then I was just like I gotta [__]
go
that was definitely like Justified
though because we're just recreating
wrestling moves and he thought it was
sick yeah like he was like he was but
that's not really bullying is it yeah he
just it was an accident yeah yeah I did
that to one of my friends I I hit him
with the rock bottom but we did it on a
bench like like a bench at school like
in the locker room and he was like and
he was I love this dude his name is John
Jung he was like this little Korean dude
and I was in middle school and then he
he was like he was really little and I
think up until like the seventh grade he
would ride in a car seat because that's
how little he was and I was little too
but I was able to lift him he was and
that's why yeah we were doing 50 pounds
even riding car seats
is a tough move to take yeah dude and on
a bench did he sell it he sold it but he
was like he was like really hurt yeah he
was like he was like oh [__] like he was
really [__] up but we were friends
after that well that's good at least you
guys are friends out there we were
hanging out I feel like there's a I
don't know if it's different now but I
feel like bullying at least when I was a
kid happened because it was like you had
like a mini Society of Friends right and
if somebody was behaving in a way that
was like
kind of uh like hey someone's gonna kick
your ass if you act like that so the
bullying was to like save somebody from
making an ass of themselves in
representation of the group because
um yeah and I don't like oh yeah like
calling out Cockiness yeah or like like
don't have a rolly backpack you're not
better than us exactly yeah okay because
we bullied this one we bullied this one
kid uh because I I we were all 12 years
old and then we were gonna go to the
Stonewood mall in Downey and uh it was
like the coolest thing back then to just
walk through the mall with your friends
right this fool showed up there was like
eight of us he showed up wearing a like
he's a dark ass Filipino guy he's
wearing a blue velvet vest like a dress
vest for a suit with no shirt underneath
why oh yeah and he's wearing like tights
you mean like a tuxedo vest yeah tight
jeans and then he has this like Walkman
that has a speaker on it and he had it
on his hip and he was playing Macarena
out loud why
he didn't think it was weird he thought
it was cool was that the first time he
did it like at least like the first time
well we didn't see each other outside of
school very much so when when I saw his
his choice of regular clothes we were
like instantly oh we need to bully this
floor this he's gonna look like this all
the time you're doing him a favor though
he got laid later because you guys like
legitly yeah so he made him feel like
total [__] we were like dude you look
[__] terrible and then we were like
we're not gonna walk around with you
like this because also it's annoying
like you have a a speaker playing
mozzaretta I kind of like getting
bullied I think I think it's helpful I
think like I remember like as a kid we
were so on our street we probably had
like four or five friends that lived on
the same street yeah so it's easy for us
to play and it was just like you wake up
in the morning if you hear like a ball
bouncing you just stick your head out
and you can see who's playing basketball
on the street and then so all the kids
are are our age we hung out but then
everyone has older brothers and stuff
and then I remember if like we're
playing and as one older brother comes
home it's almost as if like the [__]
Devil Himself came and we just [__]
booked it we're like leaving this
person's house we're doing whatever and
then maybe if that guy's bored then he
like like one of the things they love to
do is when we're riding our bikes they
would just come and like stick a
broomstick into the spokes and it would
just fly off and I remember like to me
almost felt like [__] is this the
[__] Hells Angels coming to kill me
but then later on you're like oh I kind
of like made us tough and like yeah even
though you felt like you get scratches
and you're bleeding and at that moment
you feel like your life's gonna end but
then that kind of rough house seeing it
it like I don't know I feel like it made
you tougher somehow I think so I
remember getting attention from like or
getting bullied from an older group it
kind of felt like oh Big Brothers like
it's it's just weird like because back
then we would all play outside right
like it would be like Sandlot where like
a bunch of kids on bicycles and [__] and
I remember
um these other group of guys we always
like kind of looked up to them they were
like a little bit older we were in
elementary they're in junior high and
they're playing like football and stuff
and then for us we would just like sit
there on our bikes and just watch them
and it was so-and-so's brother whatever
and one day they said hey come over here
so we're like oh us they're like you
want to play and then we're like yeah
they're like all right we're doing full
contact football we're on the ground big
kids versus little kids US versus you
guys and I was like yes and then like my
friends were all like [__] and then I'm
like well cause you're not you don't
have to play duck right now
like it sounds way better than getting
shot at like saying quack quack quack
yeah and then it's humiliating clearly
they're just having a blast like they're
not even playing football they just
wanted to grab us and slam us on the
grass like Blitz you're playing Blitz
basically like unnecessary amounts of
tackle and then they're all getting hurt
and [__] and then you know it always
ends when a kid cries yeah
don't tell your parents don't tell your
parents all right and then like they're
like all right and then you know but I
was like that's dumb let's do it again I
don't get tackled but I'm a good
candidate for being bullied yeah but it
just felt like like this like oh I'm
getting attention from the cool guys
yeah you know like they're they like me
you know but they don't and but back
then you you don't know that they're
just using you for entertainment it also
felt like some sort of rite of passage
too yeah like
um because then you would meet kids that
their older brothers or sisters didn't
bully them and you're like man you're
weird
see that's that's kind of what I always
felt like when um like bullying almost
was
an antidote for total weirdness in a way
which sucks the same unless if you
didn't know why you were getting bullied
so like girls are the worst at this like
in school they're like whisper and
you're still because it's psychological
it's more psychological and then they'll
like scatter and laugh and then you're
just like they were talking to me
yesterday I was like yeah you have no
clue so it's more people get [__] up
yeah honestly honestly it sucks like so
when you don't know why you're getting
bullied I think it's way worse well
that's a different level though girls
have pain because of men and guys have
pain because of men
physical passwords but also at the same
time so we used to play war all the time
yeah and then so like my so my best
friend his uh older brother
um was like the main bully of the big
kids so that would automatically be the
home base of all the older kids and then
since I'm having brothers and sisters
like they just felt safe at my house so
my house became like the home base for
younger kids so anytime we're like we
could be playing anything if the big
kids coming we're playing War everyone
just [__] runs away because the war
starts immediately and then so we
[__] start setting up [__] like
what we think are booby traps and [__]
because we look like they're supposed to
come and I Remember by the time they
catch us they always whoop our ass and
stuff so the first time that I ever
realized like oh [__] if you fight back
um bullies actually aren't that crazy
was these kids they toppled our booby
traps because they're just made like
retardedly and this kid named Jordan
climbed on top of the wall
and just in a state of panic I was like
oh [__] Jordan's coming I grabbed a
brick
they leave right and then I I hear
Jordan it's like they got bricks let's
get the [__] out of here Jordan crying
and he couldn't breathe he was like I
heard him get on his bike and then ride
back down to his house oh and then I was
like oh [__] and then the parents came
out and they're like oh what happened oh
we're just playing and it's also you
learned this code of like not ratting oh
because they didn't go like oh Bart did
it or whatever oh it just felt like like
through these like little like little
like chicken hierarchy pecking at each
other you kind of learn the rules of the
world and then so we're like okay we
don't want to have this play thing get
shattered and all parents come out and
go no one's playing forever so it just
kind of became this thing and then also
our bowling also got reduced because of
the brick
you kind of learned all these little
things you know yeah dude that kid had a
broken rib and he goes to the hospital
the doctor's like what happened he's
like
[__] fell off my bike I'm saying [__]
thing damn yeah we just learned
different era dude so many little things
I'm glad I got bullied dude straight up
I really am I wouldn't have probably
done anything I ever did in life if I
wasn't a like bullied hardcore yeah like
from from a formative age like I think
it just gave me like surviving that or
whatever you call that yeah it just gave
me confidence like later on where I was
like how do you teach someone to respond
that way to it it's a touchy part well
either you're productive with it or
you're just gonna suffer because then
there's people that we you'll meet some
days and they'll just go oh that was the
worst time of my life and they have no
like positive and that's kind of sad you
know right like how do you combat
psychological bullying when you're
outnumbered right like whatever you
learned and I learned the same thing
like I don't I can't pinpoint what that
is that is hard to say because Taiko
will say [__] like that sometimes like
he'll have the best day ever right we do
everything he ever wanted we even go to
[__] get [__] donut with Oreos on it
like the best day ever and then there's
like one thing like let's say we're
supposed to play Uno tonight and we're
supposed to play three rounds we only
have time to play one azer put him to
bed
about this and then like after he comes
to go oh yeah that was a really really
good day because he couldn't do three
rounds of Uno yeah yeah but like it's
just when you're when you're such a kid
it's like hyper fixated yeah hyper fix
it on that moment you forget about
everything yeah and then it made me
think like but when we were kids like
kids that got bullied and actually liked
it we didn't have someone to talk us
through it we have to kind of like teach
ourselves those lessons and I wonder how
yeah like how we did that also it
depends on the the severity of bullying
like sometimes it gets so bad like The
Hazing and all that like people die
right like that's that level yeah that's
not even so then that's crazy it does it
does happen and all of our experiences
are are are different but I feel like
it's like some people can take different
doses of something and and like I think
like well it's hazing in in certain
cultures too is just like common right
like like I would say Frack culture or
like
um even in like Japanese and Korean
Culture The Hazing is almost like this
this like closeness like you go through
like severe hazing and then you almost
have to be a footstool to someone older
than you you know it's crazy so there
was a kid on our street too he was this
Indian kid that wore glasses and
everyone just knew he's off limits like
he's such a [__] little [__] he
wasn't even didn't have the honor that
is also not fun too it's not fun yeah uh
that's there's also this theme where
it's like I think because you see like
when you were when you get bullied
you're almost like oh I'm kind of worthy
of this group yeah whereas if someone
just goes oh that's like too easy of a
Target they just left them alone right
and then they become loners and then you
kind of are envious yesterday but then
he doesn't feel pain every day yeah he
do yeah but then also like but I'm also
kind of accepted in this really weird
way you know versus the kid that was
just like everyone's like he's a [__]
like he's gonna whine a rap tattletail
and all this yeah I think I learned I
learned that specific thing in eighth
grade I had this uh this friend of mine
who's I went to school with him almost
every year of my life until Community
College from like fourth grade and he's
one of my best friends now and uh
basically I bullied him like I think it
was like in fifth grade to like sixth
grade I didn't know I was bullying him
but then I kind of knew I was I just
didn't like him because he was fat and
also like he was smarter than me so then
I just didn't so I would do things that
would kind of like be directed at him
but passive aggressively I would be like
hey guys I'm starting a VIP program if
you want a slice a pizza uh you just
gotta like join my program and I'll give
you a pizza at lunch because I would get
eight slices of pieces as my lunch all
you gotta do is not be fat so give me
like the whole box yeah get a whole
Tony's Pizza in My Lunchbox so I'd give
him I would eat that I would eat all
that much so I would give it to my
friends and I would be like he'd be like
well how do I join the program like oh
you gotta have this one comic book that
I don't like only these guys have he's
like oh go get it and then he like gets
it I'm like I changed the rules of my
brother
oh
my God I would always ask him like I
would always tell them like drink I'll
get him in trouble a lot like during
class I'd be like hey dude Richard Nixon
impersonation you do it and I'd pull
this chair out you [__] [__] like
I [__] with him so hard for like and I
thought it was just funny and then like
in eighth grade we're like a little
older and I was like hey bro remember
like in sixth grade when I used to do
this thing and he goes hey you know like
you kind of ruined my life man
he goes that wasn't fun for me man I
really thought like my life was over
and I was like
what like right I wasn't thinking like
that level at all yeah and he was like
no like that that was the worst year
because you just don't know how they're
gonna take it well also Ryan's such a
like prankster by Nature yeah it's in
your blood baby I mean it was definitely
malicious because yeah I didn't but bro
if I was if I was in his shoes I would
just laugh about it and then one day
I'll bring pizza and not let you have
some like whatever right because I'm
like having be target practice from my
own brother so like the the severity of
what I went through at home was like
that's nothing but it's depending on the
person but also when you're in sixth
grade that is the worst thing that ever
happened here like that sixth graders
everybody followed my lead on how he
treated him so then they all did yeah
you know how like Anthony when we all
joke about it and someone new comes and
they go oh we're ripping on Anthony and
then they do it and Anthony goes I don't
like I don't even know if you yeah
that's the thing it's like maybe if it
was just me he'd be like oh Ryan's an
idiot but then if everyone goes oh I
want to also do that then it feels
overwhelming and I learned I learned it
that year that like oh [__] like I
didn't take into account his whole life
he's the only child he like didn't have
any like friends in his neighborhood
like he lived in [__] gangster ass
Norwalk but I bet he's better for it and
he had to pay and he had to pay yeah and
I wasn't gonna let him have a [__]
Pizza
okay no days off
Sorry rules changed again sorry
that's the hustle
can you wake up and be like
what I would literally try to I would
let me try to acquire the basketball
cards I knew he needed and I would just
Bogart that much to be like I'm not
trading this one out no I'm sorry I
would do everything for like but that's
what kids do at that age bro like
they're all little [__] but it is
true that like if I had done that to a
different kid he could have laughed
every single one of those things off but
it just depends man yeah you just never
know did you apologize I did yeah I
apologize and for for the rest of our
lives for the rest of our friendship I'm
like hey sorry I was such a [__] dick
yeah you know what I mean one of my
closest friends growing up he um
he has an accent because you know he
just came from Vietnam he so so it's
like he was easy bullying Target right
and he was a nerd and he was like he
never fought back and in one day he just
snapped and he beat this guy up and did
like a bar slide all over there
yeah he grabbed him and he [__] did
it super bar slide into the arcade
machine yeah on the table pretty tight
and he told me that was the moment like
his Bart's brick moment where he became
Revenge hungry oh and from that that's
his bill and origin story all the way
until even recently he told me this
story like a couple months ago where he
had a road rage incident with a UPS
driver and then the UPS driver wanted to
like talk [__] because we got doors
the UPS driver was was like pull over
my friend goes out and they have a fist
fight oh my God and yeah and he goes oh
and then the UPS driver knew like fight
how to fight like he knew MMA so they're
just throwing down he's like you're
never getting a [__] package again
dude I'll make sure of it but he said it
was one of those it was one of those
things where like they just shook hands
and afterwards they're like damn you
fight but but he's like he's just
constantly fighting right ever since
jeez he's punched he dude I remember we
ate we were eating Pho at a restaurant
one day and in the middle of it he's
arguing with my buddy about I forgot
what the argument was but in the middle
of the argument he [__] lays them out
across the table and he gets up and
starts walking away and I was like what
the [__] so then he's on the ground and
I pick him up and I'm like chasing after
I'm like what are you doing he goes I'm
so embarrassed I can't believe I did
that I'm gonna walk home I don't think I
should drive with you guys walk down on
the bill yeah unbelievable
[Laughter]
but I feel like that's the Dark Side of
like bullying right is like someone can
snap you got the School shooters we got
all these things where like they don't
know how to handle it and then they
become Revenge hungry because they've
been feeling so small for so long like
anybody looks at them weird they're like
oh you're trying to bully me I'm gonna
[__] you up you know yeah and I think
that's the that's the really downside of
where it can go or it could go to kids
like just being isolated and then like
yeah you know
um so I I'm like how do you create a
good healthy environment of challenging
social situations there are gonna be
bullies there are going to be people
that are [__] up and you can't really
shelter them from the realities because
no you can't they just end up weeks
you're going to go into the real world
and then now you're working at companies
now you're like just walking going to
7-Eleven there's a [__] [__] like
and now you're breaking down from
anxiety yeah but once you learn to push
back that's key yeah because dude that's
the dance that's the dance yeah because
I when Once because I was getting real
bullied really bad I was part of this
basketball team they're all [__]
very quickly but then um one day I
basically just shoved this guy up
against the locker and I was like Hey
[__] off and that was all I had to do
and after that he didn't [__] with me
anymore because they liked it I was a
big dude who they could push around and
I didn't do anything because my mom the
guy I believe yeah because my mom would
always say walk away be the bigger
person and I'm like this sucks Mom I'm
like this plan sucks I'm gonna do
something different and as soon as I did
that it was over it was over and so but
if you learn that right
um now I take that with me through life
right my HOA was [__] with me and
then I just made I went to enough
meetings and I got enough people to come
to the HOA meeting and now those guys
are being removed from like the little
board and [__] so much don't [__] with
me dude just go [__] with somebody else
that's the lesson like you're gonna do
something about it I will I'll take it
to the ends of the Earth right and that
that gets forged from constant testing
right that's how you gain that I learned
how to deal with those kinds of people
yeah and yeah so push back yeah do
something it's inspiring
foreign